in just a few weeks now thousands of
ccsd students will be back in the
classroom for the first time in nearly a
year
campuses will reopen in phases on march
1st
starting with pre-k through third grade
bianca holman is live in our newsroom
with more on the district's plan hi
bianca
afternoon alex the district has
developed this 235 page document
and it's outlining the reopening plan to
protect students and adult
it shares cleaning of the cleaning
protocols and what students can expect
when they return
now the young students will start on a
hybrid model of learning
including face-to-face instruction on
march 1st
all students and staff must wear face
coverings with a few exceptions
custodians will have enhanced enhanced
cleaning protocols
plus updated hvac technologies are in
the works to improve
indoor air quality now for recess this
is a big one
students must remain socially distant
whether in the building
or outside and teachers must watch to
ensure they remain
six feet apart the food service
department will also
be implementing a safety plan to give
out lunches safely
and then while some parents are looking
forward to this some teachers say
there is confusion over cohorts the
guide also has sample schedules it talks
about the airflow on the school buses
and demonstrates the classroom layout
i'm very confident in their health and
safety measures they're going to take
for the children
as well as their transition timeline if
we're going to be going back in the
classroom we have to
really you know be able to have a
manageable workload that is the biggest
thing
the head of the cdc says we should not
wait until all teachers are vaccinated
there was a study last week from the cdc
doctors that showed schools
that reopened in the fall did not
contribute to the spread of coveit 19
in any meaningful way and we have a link
to ccsd's full 235 page guide on our
website
at 8newsnow.com reporting bianca holman
8 news now